you can be useful yeah
I'm stand behind me look Chad we had to
put you on this list out of principle
but don't get twisted about it you're
far from being one of the most powerful
aks in auradon well you could be if you
wanted to but you're sort of a
scaredy-cat
and that's okay to each their own we
would cower in front of Audrey too if
she were our girlfriend but all jokes
aside we think you have potential Chad
and we really hope you find your mother
Cinderella's courage somewhere down the
line our favorite characters from The
Descendants franchise have got some
wicked cool powers and we're about to
rank them from weakest to strongest keep
watching to find out which unexpected a
came eat it into the top five you'll
never see it coming
[Music]
Chad charming it should come as no
surprise that Chad charming is
considered one of the weakest ak's in
auradon Chad's parents are Cinderella
and Prince Charming both of whom have
zero powers to account for but we
wouldn't exactly call Chad powerless
sure he gives cowards a bad name but he
sure knows how to use his charm to get
what he wants it's easy to see that Chad
likes getting his way he turned on Evie
in the first Descendants film when she
couldn't complete his homework and he
nearly got her expelled chad has some
serious manipulation skills and he's not
afraid to put them to good use problem
is he's afraid of everything that goes
bump in the night Doug makes our movie
night scene a little tame
movies Doug may not be the most powerful
a Kay but what he lacks in strength he
makes up for encouraged if there's one
thing that keeps Doug going it's the
thought of losing Evie Doug would climb
the tallest mountain and rescue Evie
from a tower guarded by a dragon if it
came down to it Doug is the son of dopey
who doesn't have any magical powers of
his own however he does have a very good
work ethic that he passed down to Doug
Doug may come off as nervous and nerdy
but don't let that guy fool you there's
a huge brain cooking up a master plan
beneath that shake Oh on his head dizzy
Germain dizzy Germain may be physically
weaker than Doug and her step cousin
Chad but she grew up on the Isle of the
Lost which makes her three times as
tough Dizzy's the daughter of Drizella
Tremaine who doesn't have any powers of
her own unless you count complaining of
course dizzy was raised by her
grandmother Lady Tremaine who made sure
that she was a hard worker from the
get-go dizzy is brave and selfless which
are two qualities every hero has in the
bag but when it comes to disease natural
born abilities we'd have to say she's
got the power of style
the young VK is also super resourceful
which came in handy when dizzy gave Evie
and mal the tools to make smoke bombs in
descendants - Audrey Audrey may have
been the big bad of descendants three
but that doesn't make her the most
powerful aka in auradon after all
Audrey's powers came from Maleficent
staff and were not of her own designs
without the staff Audrey is just a
princess with a big personality you're
new here aren't you
I am Audrey princess Audrey just like
Chad Audrey knows exactly what to say to
manipulate people and although it isn't
the best hour it gets the job done
before the vks came to Oregon Audrey was
running the show which just goes to show
how powerful she can be without using a
lick of magic Audrey may not have
magical abilities running through her
veins but she's still a dangerous person
she'll do just about anything to get
what she thinks she deserves King then
King then showed us just how strong he
could be in descendant 3 when he turns
into a movie
but then again that was Audrey's doing
not his own as it turns out the king of
auradon doesn't actually come from a
magical bloodline so he doesn't have any
powers whatsoever unless you count
diplomacy but the fact that Ben has no
powers doesn't make him powerless he's a
skilled athlete who knows how to use a
sword and he knows how to drive a car
which can come in handy when a quick
getaway is afoot but most importantly
Ben is brave and wants to help others
making him a total hero Lonnie Lonnie
isn't someone you want to underestimate
because she'll come back swinging like
there's no tomorrow she's the daughter
of Mulan and li Shang so clearly she
knows how to use a sword Lonnie is one
of the most open-minded a case in
auradon she helped the Corps for save
King Ben from the Iowa in descendants to
proving how much of a team player she
can be Lonnie is trained in martial arts
and has the heart of a true hero on top
of being a skilled fighter Lonnie is
also super smart and has proven time and
time again that she's a leader not a
follower Airy hook parry hook suffers
from DK syndrome which basically means
that he wants to make his father proud
above all else this has led Harry to
develop a super cynical and evil
personality but clearly Harry hook isn't
who he pretends to be after all why
would an evil person help the court for
save auradon
Harry doesn't have any magical abilities
but he is a skilled swordsman fighter
and thief berry also possesses a knack
for intimidation
just like his dad Captain Hook parry is
a pirate through and through he's a
master navigator who always has a sharp
hook handy skill Gill may be a part of
Emma's pirate gang but the boy doesn't
have a mean bone in his body you might
find it surprising that Gil is more
powerful than Harry but in the end Gil
has brute strength on his side Gil is
the son of Gaston who doesn't have any
magical abilities but despite inheriting
his father's denseness Gil also
inherited an extreme strength just like
Harry Gil is a skilled swordsman and
pirate is
his downfall is that he's a follower and
not a leader making him the perfect
henchman but seat down Gil would rather
fight alongside heroes than villains
Jay Jay maybe the son of Jafar but he
doesn't possess many of his powers
apparently sorcery and divination skip a
generation but Jay has still managed to
become one of the strongest BK's from
the aisle
Jay is super strong and possesses the
ability to do parkour which makes
catching him comparable to finding a
needle in a haystack Jay is a skilled
fighter and an athlete who knows how to
steal your wallet by shaking your hand
despite being raised by defarge a loves
auradon and everything it stands for he
risked his life to save others on more
than one occasion
making him brave and selfless which are
two strengths money can't buy Evie sorry
Doug but your girl Evie is so much
stronger than you'll ever be
not that you mind of course you support
her no matter what
Evie might not seem like a super
powerful lady when standing next to mal
but she has more than a few tricks up
her sleeve Evie is the daughter of the
Evil Queen so she was born with magical
abilities unfortunately for her she
couldn't tap into them while living on
the Isle
however Evie can cast some super-strong
spells she's also a skilled fighter who
knows how to use a sword she leads by
example is super intelligent and of
course she's got a very powerful fashion
influence now let's find out which
descendants made it into the top five
Jane you might be surprised to find out
that the sweet and innocent Jane made it
into the list of the top five most
powerful descendants but it's wise to
remember that Jane is the daughter of
the all-powerful fairy godmother you
know the one responsible for trapping
every single villain on the Isle of the
Lost
Jana's super intelligent organized and
helpful without her king Ben would have
been trapped as a beast for a super long
time Jane possesses the same powers as
her mother however she was raised to
fear magic which is why her skills
aren't as developed Jane tried to use
her mom's wand in the first descendants
film only to succeed in blowing a hole
in the barrier so yeah
she needs to work on her skills but
she's powerful nonetheless Carlos
Deville Carlos and his girlfriend Jane
have both made it into the top five
making them the most powerful
descendants couple of all time
Carlos possesses the ability to cast
spells and manipulate magic which is
strange since his mother Cruella isn't
magical whatsoever so Carlos probably
got these skills from his dad's side of
the family Carlos is a tech prodigy who
is always one step ahead of everyone
else he's skilled in combat knows how to
drive and he's one of the smartest
people in auradon this friendly brave
animal lover may have grown up terrified
on the Isle but he's not scared anymore
now that the lovebirds are out of the
way let's find out who made it into the
top three Celia bacilli a celia facili a
is by far one of the strongest because
on the Isle sure she can't defend
herself physically but what she lacks in
strength she makes up for in wickedness
just like her father dr. faciliate Celia
can sheep create and manipulate darkness
and shadows she also got some friends on
the other side who know how to pick a
fight I got friends on the other side
Celia is smart resourceful and
manipulative she has her own deck of
shadow cards that she can use to warp
the future Celia has only begun to tap
into these powers but the time she
graduates from Oregon prep she'll be the
strongest fortune teller in all the land
uma our runner-up for the title of the
strongest descendants is none other than
uma she's the daughter of Ursula and
she's not afraid to show it just like
her mom
uma can wield sea magic with the help of
her seashell necklace she can even cast
spells straight out of mouth spell book
as shown at the end of descendants - uma
can transform herself into a huge
sequoia on top of being magically gifted
uma is this
field fighter a leader and an expert
navigator despite coming off as a
villain in descendants to house my home
someone needs to be there to protect it
Loula is a total hero now surprise
surprise the strongest descendants is
mal daughter of Hades and Maleficent
both mouths parents are known for their
immense powers and wrath
it wasn't until d3 that we found out
that mal is a demigod which is why she
blows Emma's powers out of the water
Malkin transformed him into a
fire-breathing dragon and she's amazing
at casting spells and brewing potions
mouths got some amazing dexterity too
she can hold a sword as easily as she
holds a paintbrush now puts all of her
friends powers to shame but luckily for
them she's a queen not a villain if you
could possess powers of your own which
ones would you choose and why sound off
in the comments and that's a wrap if
that subscribe button and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time on the themes
[Music]